thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
live from Keith this evening where this
time last year Vladimir Putin was about
to launch his illegal invasion of
Ukraine as we Mark that Milestone the
former prime minister Boris Johnson
tells Sky News British security is at
risk unless Ukraine wins and warns
Beijing against arming Moscow
this is an absolutely critical moment
for the world this is a this is a pivot
moment this is a hinge of Faith this is
the decisive moment in the early 21st
century
Sky News learns how the prime minister
is being urged to boost military
spending to rebuild ammunition stores
and tonight the United Nations votes
overwhelmingly to demand Russia
withdraws from Ukraine but China and
India abstain
foreign
police in Northern Ireland arrest three
men in connection with the shooting of a
senior detective attacked in front of
his young son
genius attack when John Caldwell last
night involved not just John but also
our children so those people showed no
humanity and they attacked our children
Palmer sets out his key targets if labor
wins the next general election
[Music]
first of all they thought it was a knee
injury then somebody said sagalo had
dropped him then it was all a mistake
and then we were told it was definitely
true and then suddenly here's the new
cheat sheet
and the tributes to John motson one of
football's most distinctive voices
following his death at the age of 77.
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 40.
[Music]
good evening from Kiev in Ukraine and
welcome to a special extended version of
Sky News at 10 just a few hours away
from the anniversary of the Russian
invasion of this country Vladimir
Putin's actions have threatened the
stability of Europe and caused shock
waves around the world but Ukraine has
remained defiant against the odds with
allies pledging their unwavering support
tonight Whitehall sources have told Sky
News the UK is reviewing the size of its
ammunition stockpiles amid concern that
they are far too small and I have
returned to soltifka in khakiv to see
how the lives of those there have been
ruined by a year of War but first in an
exclusive interview for Sky News Boris
Johnson has told me the UK should
provide president zielinski with Typhoon
fighter jets he also warned Beijing not
to support Moscow and said defeat for
Ukraine would spell disaster for the
rest of the world
the astonishing thing about where we are
today is nobody thought that the
ukrainians were going to hold out for a
week if you remember let alone a year or
very few people thought they would
resist in the heroic way that they have
and it's absolutely crucial that we give
them the suppliers the support they need
to get on and finish it this 2023 has
got to be the year of victory for
Ukraine that's the best thing for
Ukraine by the way it's the best thing
for the the Russian people it's the best
thing for the world it's the Humane
thing and let's get on with it should
the UK and other NATO countries be on a
war footing because who knows where this
war is going to lead I don't know what
you exactly mean by a war footing Mark
what I'm saying is that we should
continue to supply the Munitions that we
can we need to make more Munitions and
we should recognize when you talk about
the expense
making sure that we are able to save
money save defense expenditure in the
long term because as we just discussed
the risk of any kind of success
by Vladimir Putin is that our general
security would be much more Gravely
imperiled that's why it's essential to
do what we're doing now if Rishi sunat
doesn't significantly increase defense
spending in the next budget would he be
failing as a wartime leader well this is
there's a there's a there's a couple of
sort of ifs there uh Mark and I think
that uh I I pay tribute to the
government's prime minister defense
secretary what they're continuing to to
do and the UK remains way out uh in in
front it's one of the the big donors uh
to Ukraine not just of of humanitarian
assistance but of that crucial military
assistance and what I'm saying now is
that when it comes to things like
fighter jets of course you get what the
what the ukrainians want is uh f-16s uh
as it happens uh we don't have s16 we do
have typhoons I think there's an
argument for the UK breaking the ice and
and giving them some typhoons if it's a
question of of uh training people up to
use those machines then we can do that
well what would the consequences be do
you think if China
actively supported Russia in this war by
supplying Weaponry I think it would be a
historic Mistake by the by the Chinese I
was very concerned to see what Wong Yi
was was doing yesterday uh in in Moscow
I I think you know it would be a big
mistake why does China want to be
contaminated by association with with
Putin who's revealed himself to be this
gangster and and adventurer I think it
would be a big mistake by by China but
what it what it shows is the the urgency
of us giving the ukrainians what they
need to succeed this year and to make
sure that 2023 is the year of Victory
the Ukrainian prime minister
said today to Sky News that if Ukraine
loses the war if Putin wins it could
well lead to a third world war uh do you
agree
but I think the stakes are very high I
think that in the sense as we discussed
earlier I just think there's a there is
a real risk that if Putin can
manufacture any kind of success out of
this then
um
he will be able to continue to threaten
not just Ukraine the rest of Ukraine but
all the parts of the former Soviet
Empire that he wants to intimidate and
everybody else around the world will
draw the conclusion Mark that that
aggression pays off and that borders can
be changed by force this is an
absolutely critical moment for the world
this is a this is a pivot moment this is
a hinge of Faith this is the decisive
moment in the early 21st century if
Ukraine wins and I think Ukraine will
win and I know Ukraine can win with our
help then that will be absolutely
critical for our security for decades to
come if on the other hand as you say
Putin is able to manufacture some kind
of Victory I think that will be a a blow
for peace stability and for prosperity
Boris Johnson there speaking to me a
little earlier well Sky News has learned
that the UK is reviewing the size of its
ammunition stockpiles because uh
Russia's invasion of Ukraine has shown
them to be far too small sources within
Whitehall have urged the prime minister
to boost military spending to fund a
major expansion in ammunition and
weapons stores but say they fear Rishi
sunak isn't interested in defense
acclaimed Downing Street denies Sky's
security and defense editor Deborah
Haynes has this report
Western weapon
weapon in eastern Ukraine
they're evening up the battlefield for
Ukrainian troops against Russia's much
larger Army
but neither side stocks are infinite
and a race is on to see who can re-arm
fastest
on Ukraine's front line near the city of
bakmut a soldier explains how this
makeshift cover protects his gun from
Russian suicide drones
he also talks about the need to preserve
ammunition
um
fire over the past
has been greater than at any time since
the Korean War
a Ukrainian officer has told Sky News
that Russia had been firing 60 000 to 70
000 shells a day a level that's about
halved as supplies ran down
U.S officials have put that top rate at
around 20 000 a day but also say it's
dropped
Ukraine by contrast has been firing 5
000 to 6 000 rounds daily
as for the impact Russia has lost around
9 000 pieces of military equipment such
as armored vehicles and artillery three
times more than Ukraine
with its tanks missiles and generosity
the UK is one of the Ukrainian
military's most important suppliers
but for how long I've been told Britain
is reviewing the size of its ammunition
stockpiles because Russia's Invasion
here has exposed how past assumptions on
what would be needed to fight a war were
far too conservative my sources say
Rishi sunac must increase defense
spending to fund a massive expansion in
ammunition and weapon stores or risk
being unable to keep supporting Ukraine
at the level needed
rebuilding the UK's military strength
after Decades of cuts is also critical
the Prime Minister talked tough when he
hosted Vladimir zelensky this month
but one Whitehall Source accused Mr
sunac of having no interest in defense
and security those charged with that in
number 10 can barely get access to him
the president zelenski visit was engaged
with late and with only peripheral
passing interest if it's not domestic or
economic it doesn't feature
a Second Source said he's a financier
and simply can't understand these things
a government spokesperson said these
claims are baseless and untrue it was
the Prime Minister who as Chancellor
agreed the 2020 spending review that
provided the ministry of Defense with
the largest increase in defense
investment since the Cold War
the prime minister is clear that we will
do everything necessary to protect our
people which is why our Armed Forces
will always have the equipment and
capability they need
of course the UK is only one of many
countries arming Ukraine but dwindling
stockpiles is a common theme that needs
fixing so the troops can keep firing
debraham Sky News Kiev
now the U.N General Assembly has voted
to pass a resolution demanding Russia
unconditionally and immediately withdraw
from Ukraine but China and India are
among a small group of countries who
have abstained uh U.S correspondent Mark
stone is at the UN in New York so well
Mark in reality what does all this mean
well by the faces of the western
diplomats inside that building late this
afternoon they are very very pleased
there were 32 abstentions China among
them of course there were seven who
voted against The Usual Suspects North
Korea Syria Iran Belarus voting with
Russia but 141 of the 193 countries that
stand in this building that are members
of the United Nations voted for this
resolution now what does it tell us yes
it's symbolic no it is not binding but
it tells us that the global resolve
against Russia and its aggression it is
overwhelming and has sustained over the
course of the past year Market it was
exactly a year ago tonight that the
security Council of the United Nations
was meeting calling for Russia not to
invade Ukraine and President Putin chose
that precise moment to go on state
television in Russia and announce the
that he was doing that that he was going
to invade and so he did it was a neat
two fingers to this institution and to
the global order that it represents and
I think what we will see tomorrow is
that while Global resolve is against
Putin Russia still has a hold over the
United Nations and therefore a hold over
all of this because it has the power of
veto and when the generalists when the
security Council meets tomorrow Russia
will be around that table and we will
hear once again Russia's alternate
reality in terms of what the past year
has represented
yeah we certainly will mark thank you
very much indeed now throughout the past
year the city of hakive has come under
almost constant bombardment worst hit
the area of sultivka just 20 miles from
the Russian border we have been back
there to meet the few remaining people
enduring extraordinary hardship and who
fear that it could all soon happen again
year on and saltivka remains a broken
place
broken buildings broken infrastructure
and in the grip of this cruel winter
broken people
Anatoly limerenko has a face worn by War
he is 61 years old and he is the only
person still living in his badly damaged
nine-story block of flats
[Music]
it is a hard climb to the seventh floor
place he still calls home
it is scarcely that so
it's cold it's really cold
please
he has guests to cook and soup to keep
him going but there is no heating no hot
water and the toilet doesn't work
because the system water froze and it
cracked but despite it all he stays I
have nowhere else to go he says
it's scary to be on your own but when
there is no shelling it's bearable
three kilometers stand Russian
and the bump here
during the days during the night
just after War Began we met Raman in
soltifka ferrying supplies to the
desperate here between
he is still doing it
these women show us the flats destroyed
by Russian fire
where missiles went through the floor
and where the lives of neighbors came to
an end
and living next door to the burnt out
shell of an apartment we found 71 year
old nelia tuba who is often thought
about leaving
but instead stays with her bedridden
husband Petra
they do at least have Heating in this
block
but her fear is that the Russians will
try again to take the city
this place represents Putin's War not
against the Ukrainian military but
against the Ukrainian people 40
000 people lived here now it is barely a
handful and for them the conditions are
desperate
[Music]
and a totally sitting watching jazz on a
television with barely a signal
this is what war has done to soltifka to
its few remaining people to the spirit
of what they say used to be
a happy place
[Music]
and that is about it from Ukraine for
this evening we will of course have full
coverage throughout the day uh tomorrow
now back to you in London
mark thank you
detective Chief Inspector John Caldwell
is in a critical condition in hospital
in Northern Ireland tonight he'd been
coaching football with his son and other
children at his Sports Center when two
gunmen attacked him three men have been
arrested in connection with the shooting
in Omar and the focus of the
investigation is now on the new IRA and
dissident Republicans Stephen Murphy
reports
this is a major police operation to find
those who try to assassinate their
colleague
often seen leading press conferences
this is detective Chief Inspector John
Caldwell a senior and well-respected
murder Detective
thus follows the results of the
postmortem
after coaching in under 15 football team
at this Sports Complex he was putting
footballs into his car when he was
attacked and shot multiple times by two
gunmen in front of his young son
dozens of other children were present
they ran terrified for cover as the
attackers fled the investigation quickly
focused on the new Ira three men were
arrested today as John Caldwell's
colleagues paid tributes he has a credit
to his family and to the Police Service
and of course our thoughts are with John
and his family as he fights for his life
in hospital today John Caldwell is a
past people of oma high school and
around 15 young pupils from the school
witnessed his attempted murder some were
just meters away when gunfire erupted
some kids were obviously shocked still
shocked and they they were they looked
numb and they didn't know what to say
they are worried about him and his
health and how he is coping in hospital
there's pupils in the background that
are crying and they're very emotional
about what happened last night and they
cannot cope the school is no stranger to
tragedy five pupils here died in the Oma
bombing it's sheer luck more names
aren't being added to the memorial that
heinous attack on John Caldwell last
night involved not just Jon but also our
children so those people showed no
humanity and they attacked our children
it was the Secretary of State said a
cowardly and callous attack everybody in
the police and community and actually
the community of Omar is completely
shocked by this because Society has
moved on in Northern Ireland there is no
place for violence like this
condemnation 2 from across the local
political divide there's no support for
violence here within the local Omar or
kiliklahar area
as we're looking for a brighter and
better future ahead someone who was
liked and respected by the all of the
community entire community in this area
and I think that is why that you have so
much anger and outrage DCI Caldwell
investigated the dissident murder of
this colleague grown in care more than a
decade ago he told reporters that no one
deserves to be murdered because of how
they earn their living those that seek
to drag Northern Ireland back to a
darker time sought to do just that
Stephen Murphy Sky News
Oma
a security threat against police
officers in Northern Ireland has
continued since the end of the troubles
but attacks are now much rarer
detectives are treating the
Parliamentary group the new Ira as the
primary focus of their investigation
they shot and killed the journalist Lira
McKee during riots in 2019. as we
approached the 25th anniversary of the
Good Friday agreement this latest
shooting is a harsh reminder that the
risk of violence hasn't disappeared
here's our Island correspondent David
Blevins
um
from car bombs
to gun attacks
to the attempted murder of another
police officer there's nothing new about
the new Ira the umbrella name for
Renegade Irish Republican factions still
fighting this same old war against
British rule in Ireland Alison Morris
the Belfast telegraph's crime
correspondent says they have been
heavily infiltrated by MI5 that is why
we've seen the threat level in Northern
Ireland last year lured
um because mfa's assessment was that
they had been almost mortally wounded in
terms of their ability to carry out
attacks but we always say you know and
those groups always say they only have
to get lucky once whereas the security
forces have to get lucky every single
time to thwart those attacks and I don't
think that anyone had anticipated an
attack such as what happened on DCI
Caldwell
dissident Republicans have murdered
policemen soldiers and prison officers
the journalist Lira McKee was killed
when they opened fire on police during a
riot police North and South say the
terror group has aligned with the firm
an unlikely Alliance of terrorists and
criminals it's a complex and nuanced
security situation adding to the
challenge of post-brex attentions and
threatening the fragile pace
Tony Blair the Prime Minister who
co-brokered the Good Friday agreement is
calling for leadership how capable are
the political leaders of today of
grasping
the nuances of Northern Ireland and
helping to resolve it if they think the
piece has been a good thing
remember this one
principle which is actually a principle
about leadership it only came about
because of leadership
it only came about because there were
leaders prepared to be unpopular even
with their own Grassroots constituency
or part of it and it only came about
because there were Leaders with the
creativity and the imagination to say
whatever the obstacles we're going to
find their way through and they found it
it's a chilling reminder of why policing
in Northern Ireland is different to
anywhere else in the United Kingdom the
fears of the past are never far from the
hopes of the future David Blevins Sky
News in Belfast
Boris Johnson has made an intervention
over Northern Ireland casting doubt on
Rishi sunax attempts to renegotiate a
post-brexit trade deal and questioning
the prime minister's whole approach
there's been no power sharing devolved
government at Stormont for over a year
now after talks broke down I think the
the best way forward as I've as I said
when I was uh running the government is
is the Northern Ireland bill it fixes
all the the problems it it solves uh the
problems that we have in the in the uh
uh
solves the problems uh of paperwork uh
vat and so on it's a it's a it's an
excellent Bill and doesn't set up any
other problems uh in the economy of the
of uh of the whole island of Ireland
political editor Sam Coates is in
Downing Street for us tonight and Sam
what impact do you think Boris Johnson's
comments will have
well I think this is perhaps the most
destabilizing set of comments that Boris
Johnson has made as an ex-prime minister
at one of the most delicate moments for
Rishi sunak what the former prime
minister is doing is arguing that
perhaps Richardson likes the entire
approach to brexit and Northern Ireland
is misguided and that far from
negotiating with Brussels he's
suggesting that might cause uh problems
uh he's saying that actually what
Richard C Knight should do is just
continue through Parliament with his
legislation that would allow the UK to
rip up unilaterally parts of the brexit
deal he says that would solve all the
problems that there are at the moment
with brexit and Northern Ireland a lot
of people disagree would disagree with
that suggest that there are quite a lot
of risks attached to unilaterally
ripping up a treaty but that's what
Boris Johnson is doing and he's doing so
at this very sensitive moment for really
quite some time some months now Richie
see now and his team have been
negotiating with Brussels to try and
solve some of those issues in Northern
Ireland when it comes to trade when it
comes to who is in control of the laws
and sovereignty and he's quite close to
coming back with a deal now he hasn't
publicly said what's in it but we at Sky
News no we put them in the public domain
this week and they're building up quite
ahead of opposition and now the man in
the building behind me they've got to
decide whether to press ahead with this
plan publish it and try and pass it or
whether it's a pause it renegotiate or
whether to abandon it all together
because the opposition is just too much
and it's against that backdrop that
Boris Johnson's criticisms have been
made and it doesn't help Rishi sunak one
bit he will not be thanking Boris
Johnson for tonight's interview with
Mark Austin
Sam thank you
secure stammer has laid out his vision
for government pledging to give the
country its future back the labor leader
promised that if his party wins the next
general election the UK would have the
fastest growing economy in the G7 by the
end of his first term in office making a
speech in Manchester he said it was part
of five missions that he would
prioritize in power here's our political
editor Beth Rigby
pitching a path to power a general
election some time off but the campaign
now very much on I didn't realize we're
gonna have all the people up on the
other floors this a leader on the up in
polls now laying down his plans for
office
Mission driven government an answer to
the widespread call to fix the
fundamentals
a long-term plan to unlock our pride and
our purpose a profound statement of
intent
five missions to grow the economy and
improve opportunities become a clean
energy Powerhouse improve the NHS and
make our streets safe but will it cut
through people want their country to
work but can you honestly say that your
Blue Sky Thinking rather than clear
specific policies such as cutting work
in people's taxes or ensuring that
they'll get a Hospital appointment is in
any way relatable
you're quite right to say look what's
what are you gonna do about the NHS this
winter what are you going to do about
energy bills
um this spring but the problem if we
stop there with that sort of retail
offer for the here and now is that we'll
never fix the fundamentals we've had 13
years of sticking plaster politics we've
had 13 years of going round and round in
circles people here have an appetite for
change but they're not yet sure what
that looks like
he's keeping everything vague enough
that it you know ticks all the boxes
without actually
cementing a position do you sort of feel
you know what he stands for well not
particularly do you think storm is
better for the labor party there's more
chance of getting elected than Gordon
Avenue it doesn't matter what you do
then or who you vote for like nothing
will change yeah 100 so you don't trust
any politicians no
and that lack of trust is hurting the
conservatives labor are now 25 plus
points ahead in the polls not
necessarily because people like labor
but rather they seem to dislike this
conservative government and Sir
kierstarma is now trying to begin to
seal the deal with voters these five
missions will form the skeleton of the
next Labor Manifesto but what it all
boils down to is still so very vague
there's still no meat on the bones when
it comes to either policy or priorities
he can't quite believe his luck after
suffering the worst election defeat
since 1935 bringing labor back must have
felt like Mission Impossible but there's
still some way to go yet Beth Rigby Sky
News in Manchester
for the first time some Asylum Seekers
will not be required to attend a
face-to-face interview to have their
applications heard as the government
attempts to tackle the backlog of cases
it comes as the Asylum backlog has
reached a record high the latest figures
show the numbers of people waiting for a
decision hit 160
919 in the year to December 2022
now Asylum Seekers from five countries
Afghanistan Eritrea Libya Syria and
Yemen who applied before July 2022 will
have their cases decided through a
10-page questionnaire rather than
through an in-person interview the home
office says it's because more than 95
percent of Asylum claims from those
countries are accepted
well that's 12 000 people being
fast-tracked through the Asylum system
our communities correspondent Lisa
Holland reports
this is a food bank in the West Midlands
where the vast majority of recipients
are Asylum Seekers It's set up to
support people whilst they wait for
their claims to be processed
for some that can mean years trapped in
a buckling system unable to officially
work or move on with their lives
as we film watch the face of the man on
the left 18 year old Hassan Batha as a
translator explains he fits the cohort
of people whose applications will now be
fast-tracked
is from Syria and arrived in July 2021
so do you actually just broken the news
to this man yeah and it actually I've
just seen his face change he's smiling
now
he's here her dream he can live in this
country in peace
for the list of five countries has left
others like Bara majara and his
seven-year-old son bitterly disappointed
they are from Iran which has seen major
anti-government protests
I escape from there because of my
religion I'm Christian
they don't like me or they there is not
really a freedom of religion or that's
why I left Iran
it means the fear of
a still hangs over others we meet Iraqi
kurd Kamal Hassan says his son lives in
fear of his parents being sent to Rwanda
same same Iraq and Afghanistan Same Same
by my
my my government is no good
those who are eligible for the new
policy will have to fill out a 10-page
questionnaire rather than an in-person
interview if people don't have the right
help to fill in the forms there would be
a slight concern that that might
Prejudice the outcome but you know
overall if there's a fast tracking
system you know that is to be welcomed
the Prime Minister has pledged to cut
the backlog of Asylum Seekers but new
figures show nearly 161
000 claims are still awaiting processing
a record number
critics describe the announcement as an
amnesty in all but name others say it
speeds up claims which would almost
certainly be approved Mr Holland Skies
the football commentator John Monson has
died at the age of 77. his unmistakable
distinctive voice and a sheepskin coat
accompanied thousands of matches and saw
him cover 10 World Cups affectionately
known as motti he was admired for his
enthusiasm and ability to capture the
excitement on the pitch in a career
which spanned 50 years Rob Harris looks
back at the life of a legendary figure
in British sports broadcasting
[Applause]
it mattered so much was John Watson
summoning the words for the occasion
that's a fantastic quote on one I think
which will live with Wimbledon phones
forever feeling the emotion and
enthusiasm of wimbledon's FA Cup
Euphoria 35 years on his commentary
endures for fans
[Applause]
sheepskin coats the microphone people
have grown up with him they've been used
to him covering big matches and
sometimes Cup finals England games just
won't be the same without hearing his
voice
but Donald Trump
Watson was the voice of football on the
BBC Radford he voiced game-changing
moments and those moments changed him
[Applause]
a television commentator the crowd are
invading the pitch when lowly Hereford
shot Newcastle it elevated motson's
fledgling career hold the cups and the
glasses back home he would be the voice
of 29 FA Cup finals and cover 10 World
Cups
you can smash
the mutson grew in an era without daily
live games with a handful of channels
and fewer commentators
I'm still Rick Amelia what a fantastic
run making live assignments even more
coveted
[Applause]
I mean it was competitive and we both
did our best and in his best worked out
to be better than my best here we will
be remembered as a man with the finest
record of commentary on the game of
football uh that's existed
um the thing is absolutely proof that
and he deserves every compliment that
will be offered to him that gentleman
with the white hair is a Brighton season
ticket holder
and he also happens to be a local
clergyman and father of the commentator
John Watson's tip was talk little say a
lot he always found the right words
commentary living as long in the memory
as the moment he was the soundtrack to
Rob Harris Sky News